en miconi bert se convirtió en la nueva
jueza de la corte suprema de eeuu con
ella el máximo tribunal del país se
inclina hacia la derecha con seis
magistrados conservadores y tres
progresistas a una semana de las
elecciones presidenciales la velocidad
con la que se denominó se confirmó en el
senado y se juramentó a la jueza de 48
años es inédita en el país los
demócratas aseguran que los republicanos
se esforzaron en hacerlo así
precisamente para que en caso de que
haya una elección disputada del 3 de
noviembre sea la corte la que tenga la
última palabra
y me windspot
pueden ganar esta votación pero en el
proceso acelerará en el precipitado
declive de la fe en nuestra institución
nuestra política el senado y la corte
suprema en quart
y será una nueva indignación a una
nación ya dividida y enojada y abrirá
una herida en esta cámara que tardará
mucho en sanar caminan por un camino
peligroso
el propio sol ya ha dicho que cree que
las elecciones terminarán en la corte
suprema y en medio de la pandemia de
kobe 19 el presidente ha afirmado sin
pruebas que el voto por correo generará
fraude es entonces cuando la corte
suprema- entraría a decidir el voto de
barrett será decisivo ya que sería muy
probable que el mandatario consiguiera
al menos cinco votos a favor un proceso
como el que ocurrió en el año 2000
cuando el entonces candidato a la
presidencia al golf apeló a la corte
suprema para un recuento en la votación
luego de varias denuncias de fraude
al final la corte suprema ordenó la
suspensión del recuento y george w.bush
se convirtió en el nuevo inquilino de la
casa blanca